so we've been talking about how there's
a real question mark as to what
right-wing media is going to look like
over the next two years and four years
in the biden presidency
and we are if if there is any signal
about it
over the last 24 to 48 hours it's that
it's going to be absolutely and
completely nuts now we covered during
the trump administration
fox business host maria bartoromo who
used to be a
very solid reporter on cnbc uh 20 years
ago when i
started watching cnbc as i got into the
financial markets and trading stocks and
the like and
during the trump administration she
became nothing short of
a complete and total trump brown noser
doing sycophantic softball interviews
and repeating
the most ridiculous uh conspiracy
theories including over the last two
months that donald trump was going to
figure out a way to be sworn in
for another four years when clearly he
was not and uh this week
she asserts without evidence that at the
january sixth trump
riots there were democrats dressed up
like mega trump people there is no
evidence of this
this is as baseless as it was really
antifa
in disguise it doesn't seem to affect
maria bartoromo's willingness to repeat
it take a listen to this
well security in the nation's capital is
at an unprecedented level this morning
ahead of the inauguration tomorrow
a new report says that some far-right
protesters have discussed
posing as members of the national guard
to infiltrate the inauguration
the way democrats infiltrated
two weeks ago and put on mag up clothing
acting secretary of defense chris miller
says that there is no intelligence about
a potential insider threat to the
inauguration
so no one did that democrats didn't do
that
that's a lie uh black lives matter
didn't dress up as trumpists on january
6th
antifa didn't dress up as trumpists on
january 6. there's no evidence for that
whatsoever
and what i see here is maria bartoromo
desperately trying to have credibility
and relevance but lying as usual like
sean hannity
realizing wait a second i used to be
friends with the president
now i'm not friends with the president
anymore i'm out
and she's looking for something to cling
to and
this claim about storming the k was it
was democrats in disguise
storming the capital on january 6th it's
truly bonkers
but what's really crazy is this
four-year period of being a brown-nosing
trump sycophant and repeating the most
ridiculous baseless hair brain
conspiracy theories
it seems to have gotten maria bartiromo
a possible promotion
fox news has announced that six hosts
are going to get
informal week-long tryouts to become the
permanent hosts
of the 7pm eastern hour on fox news
which they're going to call fox news
prime time
maria bartiromo is one of the hosts
who's going to get a week
trial like an audition of sorts and uh
also getting
uh auditions for this 7 p.m hour are fox
news contributors
katie pavlich who's a disaster rachel
campos duffy who i've never heard of
former congressman trey gowdy and
commentator mark stein
i believe fox and friends host brian
kilmeade
also is going to get a week trial for
that 7 p.m
hour so they are setting up for the
biden presidency they're still
trying to figure out what their approach
is going to be
but if the last 48 hours are any
indication
um the conspiracy theories will continue
the hypocrisy will continue and the
attempted brainwashing of their audience
will continue and sadly as i've said
before
because of the very very low level
of media literacy in this country it
works on a lot of people and it's often
just a race whoever gets the
whoever programs them first it's very
difficult to get them out of it and if
you quote
program people to think for themselves
to have a high degree of media literacy
to understand how to question
where they came to their conclusions how
they came to hold the beliefs they hold
if that's the programming people get
uh then you have people who think for
themselves and don't fall for this
nonsense
if you program people that everybody
else is lying to you
you can only believe me which is common
in right-wing media
and it was common to what donald trump
donald trump would say
you can't believe what you're seeing and
hearing the news is fake
just believe me if that's the initial
programming people get particularly if
they're already adults
um a ship has sailed so uh proverbially
speaking so
uh it's gonna be pretty wild for the
next couple of years and the other
question will be will be will there be
any degree of antagonism between
right-wing media
and what is left of the republican party
after trump left it in shambles and i
want to talk about that next a little
bit